so last year i graduated my master's in
computational neuroscience and right now
i should be doing my research for my phd
also in computational neuroscience on
mental health
but because of corona i'm still stuck at
home 24 7 and i cannot go to university
to do my work so i also don't really
have anyone to talk to about my research
and the work i'm doing so i thought it
would be kind of fun to share some of
the things i learned about the brain
such that you can also perhaps improve
your mental well-being your brain
functioning or just your general life
because as dick swab said you are your
brain so i think it's good to learn
about yourself through learning about
your brain so i wanted to start today a
little bit about talking about the brain
and its relationship to exercise and how
exercising can actually improve some of
your brain functioning
as well as your cognitive abilities so i
will give a little bit about how these
two relate to each other and also how
you can perhaps improve your exercise
regime to improve your cognitive
abilities without studying or working
more which is super important for all of
us because no one has the time to work
more or study harder
so grab yourself a coffee and let's have
coffee time
[Music]
so i condensed all of the papers that
have come out in the last couple of
years
and
took out the advice from there which i
will show to you right now and the
research and i also put all the
resources that i use down in the
resource section below such that if
you're really curious or you think like
oh this may not be exactly right or what
i need you can do some research on your
own so i think that most people know the
benefit of exercising for the body aka
getting six-pack abs which is what we
all run but there's actually also
evidence now showing that there is a
direct effect of exercise on cognitive
abilities as well
and cognitive abilities influence a
large part of our
life how we do in our jobs how we do on
our studies as well as even in creative
work for example if we have new creative
ideas and these type of things so you
have probably encountered in the past
this effect that you're really stuck
with an idea and then you go on a
vigorous run or just even a walk and
afterwards you kind of get unstuck or
kind of get a new inspiration or a new
idea so i will here explain some of the
mechanisms that people think are
responsible for this effect so a large
body of research has now shown that
exercise can actually directly change
your brain's function as well as
structure so the structure is just the
amount of gray matter you have and the
gray matter is kind of the spongy
material of your brain and the function
is how you use it or how much blood flow
goes to certain areas of your brain so
my teacher kind of explained it as this
that if the structure are the roads then
the function is the amount of cars that
flow on the road so if you can improve
your roads and you can improve the
amount of cars that can actually
flow on the roads
this would in general improve your brain
so yeah and that's what some people
claim that exercise can do so let's get
into some of the research
so two areas that have been shown to be
directly influenced by doing exercise is
the hippocampal area in the prefrontal
cortex so the hippocampal area is the
area that is directly related for us to
memory so it's kind of our memory center
so the prefrontal cortex has been
related to planning
decision making as well as memory
consolidation so you can imagine if you
can improve your planning that you could
make a better plan for the upcoming exam
season if you could improve your
decision making then perhaps you could
decide not to watch netflix and if you
could improve your memory or memory
retention consolidation then perhaps you
only have to memorize the information
once and already do a better job in that
regard and so we can kind of see that
exercise affects all of these areas or
all of these cognitive abilities and so
by just doing exercise we could already
improve in our job performance
as well as our school performance which
i think is really nice without doing
any extra effort on the learning front
so the evidence on how exercise directly
influences our cognitive performance is
quite diverse and quite scattered but i
will list now a few of the things that
they are pretty certain about so one of
them is that exercise improves our
visual spatial
attention or in general our attention so
really where we put our attention in the
field so you can imagine if your phone
is beeping or you're really distracted
by some other thoughts or even
distracted by things in your visual
field that you can put your attention at
the place where it has to be which is
this study book that you have to get
through so another area that has been
shown to improve weight exercise is
working memory so that's the amount of
information we can help hold temporarily
afterwards it goes to long-term memory
which has also been shown to improve and
also a link has been found between the
score that people get on an iq test and
the amount of exercise they do although
this link is a little bit complex
because you could also imagine that
people who just have a higher iq do more
exercise so it's not entirely clear if
people who exercise more have a higher
iq or if it's the other way around and
in general it has been shown that if you
improve your
overall cognitive abilities your
academic performance will go up as well
as your job performance in later life
which is kind of logical if you think
about it but it is still proven so
that's kind of nice to know that if you
improve your general cognitive abilities
the chances of you doing better at
school and your job are also higher
and
there are now two ways to do this then
study more or exercise
which i think is kind of nice another
last point i kind of want to point out
as well is that exercise not only
improves our cognitive abilities but
also our sense of well-being
and also
alleviate some of the symptoms that are
correlated with mental health disorders
such as for example depression adhd or
anorexia and i don't want to go into
each
mental disorder and how they exactly
can be helped with exercise because i
think each mental disorder really
deserves its own attention and they're
also highly personalized so it's kind of
hard to make general conclusions about
how exercise can help with these but if
you're really interested i will link a
really good article that describes some
of the benefits of exercise towards
certain mental disorders so if you're
thinking in the morning should i put in
a quick 10 minute cramming session or
take a walk outside perhaps taking the
walk-out set would actually benefit your
cognitive performance more and if not
you could at least meet a cute cat which
is always a benefit so let's say you're
now super convinced you think yes my
exercise regime will also improve all my
cognitive abilities i'm gonna run all
day and become the next ice sign i
wouldn't necessarily recommend this but
you probably also have some questions
for that as well then
such as how long should i exercise to
improve my cognitive abilities as well
as which exercises are the best to
improve my cognitive abilities so in
general research is pretty clear that
some exercise is better than none so if
you
think about your lifestyle it's really
important to just see what kind of
exercise you can already do so if you
don't move at all at the moment already
doing a 10 minutes walk a day is so much
better than just being sedentary all day
and furthermore a longer duration of
exercise has not necessarily been shown
to improve the cognitive performance
more so it's not if you do a 30 minutes
run versus a 60 minutes run that the 60
minutes run person is incredibly smarter
than the 30 minutes from the person
so in general i would just hold on to
the
body of research that shows how much is
good for your body which is between 30
and 60 minutes and this is then also
recommended for your mind and for the
type of exercise it's actually a little
bit more complex so there has been some
research that shows that coordinative
types of exercises are the best for
improving cognitive abilities so
coordinative exercises include the
following type of movements so these are
jump rope exercises sketching
balance and changes exercises
rhythmic exercises or rhythm exercises
hand-eye coordination
motor responses and motor
differentiation
so we know for some sports that these
include these types of movements
naturally so you could think of dance or
kickboxing or even some types of ball
sports such as basketball or football
and these are then opposed to exercises
that don't include these type of
movements and that's for example if you
just do your standard gym training
running
or calisthenics and that's not to say i
don't think these exercises are
extremely good for the body but if
you're thinking about also improving
your cognitive
well-being then it's perhaps nice to
include also some sports in your
exercise regime that include some type
of thieves movements or to do a sports
that naturally include these type of
movements
therefore in general it's just to say
that exercise is extremely good for your
body and your mind
try to do between 30 and 60 minutes try
to include some kind of sports in your
exercise regime that includes
coordinative movement
so i think doing this you have a really
good chance of becoming or the next
einstein or the next arnold
schwarzenegger or combining these two
into some kind of grotesque
monster that's really smart as well but
anyways you'll become the next
superhuman which is something you want i
guess so until the next coffee time and
see you bye
[Music]
you